there's no
substitute for being here this was an
unforced heir
on the part of the biden administration
i'm hoping that
there's enough political will on the
other side of the aisle
to do what they should have done in the
first place and that's not
to try to fix something that wasn't
broken
and go back to what is working
all right uh right now nothing seems to
be working at the border you're looking
at these live drone shots we're getting
along
the border here and the rio grande and
the the same area
that a lot of these senators including
senator mike braun of indiana
visited including an attention facility
for minors that's meant to hold about
250 people but presently houses more
than 4 000 largely
teenagers the senator is back home in
indiana right now he joins us out of
jasper
senator mike ron very good to have you
what did you learn yesterday senator
well it was a whirlwind
tour uh we got down there a little
before uh midnight
quickly loaded up went down to the rio
grande river where there's a port of
entry
and where there's just a stream of
illegal immigrants coming in
with signs and arrows in terms of how to
do it i
learned that all you need to do is get
halfway across the river
and you've made it because that's where
the boundary line is but that evening
to show you how brazen the other side is
the smugglers and coyotes we get down to
the river
and of course nothing's going on because
they knew we were coming
and all of a sudden you hear heckling
from the other side i
asked the border patrol well who is that
because they were speaking in spanish
said those are coyotes and smugglers
saying
regardless of what you do we're going to
keep coming
that's the way the trip started we went
back that evening you could see a stream
of mostly kids
and very young adults some infants going
into two staging areas
under an interstate uh
under a road port of entry because
there's so many people coming in
with that welcome sign that biden put
out there
and he shut everything down that trump
was doing that was working before
it's the mess now as you know the
president of the white house
has pointed to this happening many times
in the past
that there was a spike in this activity
uh back in 2019
and they blamed at the time president
trump cutting 450 billion dollars
in funding uh to mexico do you buy that
do you believe that
if you look at the map uh ron johnson
did it
lindsey graham and uh we've used it
often right here
it shows all the peaks and valleys and
the most recent one
would have been when trump started
talking about
staying place in mexico of course there
was a surge
because what impressed me most are the
people
on the other side that are making 4 000
bucks ahead
on any central american and mexican
that's per
person not family up to 20 000
on other nationalities if they can pay
more and they've got a logistics
system deal that knows how to work
the system when you give them the
opportunity it was at a 45-year
low which president biden failed to
mention
when you had the wall belt to the extent
even though you got
gaps in it where he shut it down and you
had
placement in mexico where you weren't
let into the country and you were
working with the northern triangle
countries biden politically said
we're stopping it because it was trump
he's got a fiasco
that 17 other senators witnessed as well
senator uh there are estimates here that
the number of kids crossing the border
could keep
soaring uh one study has it at as many
as 18 to 22
000 at the border in april another 25
000 in may there's no way we can keep up
with that
there's not the total figures february
was about a hundred thousand
it's going to hit about 140 000 in march
this is along the whole sector of the
southern border
texas has got four or five separate
sections themselves
and quarter million is what the border
patrol
said they're bracing for and you know
what's happening now
you get there you're so overwhelmed you
saw the pictures in the facilities there
was a biden administration
lady there telling us not to take
pictures
border patrol told us as well but you
could tell that was kind of perfunctory
and that
they knew we were going to this is going
to get only worse
rather than better we took a trip up the
river and back
spanned about a half an hour 40 minutes
and i said how can people get across
that quickly
they said they're ingenious they got a
raft system and all you need to do is
get halfway across the river
in that span of 30 or 40 minutes we come
back
there was a body floating so evidently
they tried to go through
and someone drowned in the process
in that 40-minute stretch right before
the news conference
that's the kind of stuff that's
incredible